everybody's got a question hi hey hey
hello hi okay so for today Mel's guide
you episode I'm gonna start this off
with a video response because honestly I
saw this video and it just left me
completely speechless
do you like oh I mean I guess hit a
valid question asking if I like don't
move but if you've ever seen some of my
old videos most of them involve my open
obsession
oh hey Justine can you teach me to dance
you want some dancing lessons because
let me tell you I'm gonna give those
dancing lessons to you
yeah that's right I'm a professional so
don't try this at home or I guess the
three tried at home just don't blame me
if you get hurt
Zboard who wants to know if I'm going to
get a Christmas tree in my apartment um
actually I'm probably not because I've
got this little peg right here and
that's my little Christmas pig
I'm gonna get my little hat I'm gonna
get in some more snow shoes I'm gonna
get him a sled and he's gonna be all
ready for this la winter no snow my
favorite Christmas treat is hot
chocolate with marshmallows
well good thought my iPhone just got a
proposal my friend says yes
okay so now it's a question for you guys
what do you guys do to get ready for the
holidays you have some sort of crazy
traditions or I don't know you guys tell
me leave a comment or add a video
response with any of your questions or
telling me what you guys do for the
holidays what I do is I actually just
started a tradition I'm going to make
gingerbread houses for the rest of my
life this year I made my first one and I
will show you a little clip of this and
then we can watch the whole video on the
other youtube channel youtube.com slash
iJustine yeah that's it so I'll see you
guys the next episode peace out